[Music]
at the turn of the 21st century
scientists predicted that by 2020
climate change will have increased the
number of people at risk of malaria
by 60 percent other diseases
such as mosquito-borne yellow fever and
tick-borne encephalitis
have been projected to escalate in
transmission in a warmer world
too these hypotheses were grounded in
the understanding that major vectors for
infectious diseases
like mosquitoes and ticks experience
population increases
in warmer weather over the past several
decades our planet has undoubtedly
warmed
but the trend in infectious disease
transmission has not been as clear
so what drives the transmission of
infectious diseases
and what does climate change have to do
with it
let's start by understanding what
infectious diseases
are and how they spread to humans
some of the most common and devastating
infectious diseases
include malaria west nile virus
ebola dengue yellow fever
and zika pathogens are the
micro-organisms that cause infectious
diseases
and they come in a variety of shapes and
sizes
from sub-microscopic viruses to
unicellular bacteria and protozoa
to multicellular parasites
pathogens can be divided into two broad
categories
based on how they transmit diseases to
humans
first there are anthroponoses which have
evolved to use
humans as their primary hosts
then there are zoanices which use
non-human animals
as their hosts zoanices can be
transmitted to humans directly
such as a bite from a rabbit animal or
indirectly through intermediate hosts
called
vectors vector-borne zoanises
play a key role in how climate may
influence the spread of infectious
diseases
now we can begin to answer the question
how might climate change
exacerbate infectious disease
transmission
one major aspect is the biological
response to warming
pathogens vectors and hosts each have a
range of temperatures
within which they can survive this can
be represented
as a thermal performance curve with an
organism's biological function
rising from a lower limit peaking at an
optimal temperature
and then falling at an upper limit
species with a narrow thermal
performance curve
are more vulnerable to temperature
changes while those with broad curves
are more resilient in addition to
intrinsic thermal limits
how an organism might respond to a
warmer world
also depends on its ability to regulate
its own body temperatures
shift major life cycle events such as
the timing of reproduction
or migrate to places with an optimal
climate
as higher latitudes and altitudes get
warmer
pathogen carrying vectors that are able
to
will migrate poleward or higher in
elevation
this could expose native hosts to a
disease which they have never
encountered before
and therefore have no acquired immune
response
that would help protect them aside from
these biological factors
disease transmission can also be
affected by economics
and other human actions on the one hand
human behavior could mask the effects of
climate
on an infectious disease for example
a region that has become warmer and
wetter with a climate change would in
theory
see an increase in mosquito populations
and therefore
an increase in malaria transmission
but if that region implements more
robust healthcare
or adopts preventative measures like
insecticide treated bed nets
malaria transmission might stay the same
or even
go down this explains why many wealthier
countries
despite having climates suitable for
mosquitoes have practically eradicated
malaria transmission
while less wealthy countries with
similar climates
still grapple with the disease on the
other hand
the combination of climate change
economics and human behavior
could amplify an infectious disease
for instance if climate change causes
crop failures
or livestock deaths due to floods
droughts or heat waves
people may be driven to eat or sell wild
animals
in order to alleviate food insecurity or
economic
hardship in fact scientists have
inferred
that some of the past ebola outbreaks
were caused by the hunting
and consumption of wild chimpanzees and
fruit bats
as we have learned the biological
relationship between climate change and
infectious disease
is incredibly complex and it is
complicated
by external factors and human behaviors
that may
mask or amplify the effects of a rapidly
changing climate
ecologists and epidemiologists are hard
at work trying to better understand
these questions
in the meantime don't forget your bug
repellent
[Music]
you